Thompson gets in off the glass that
won't go Davis tips it to himself for
his 11th rebound
[Applause]
James into the paint Falling Away
we got on LeBron James early for not
scoring and not looking to shoot the
basketball but he has certainly made up
being aggressive and picking his box
attacking into the paint
Thompson
[Applause]
drops inside
Thompson the drive stops
Bank Shot is good finally a bucket for
the Warriors
[Music]
right now the Lakers out there they look
exhausted Schroeder flips it up and
draws the foul boy 23 seconds remaining
here in the third
[Applause]
[Music]
LeBron James in transition again
puts his head down uses that size that
strength elevates away
looks over at the bench and deservedly
so once a breather
he's gas
21 8-7 LeBron James on the game
Schroeder misses that well in
celebration of Mental Health Awareness
Month NBA family encourages you to be
good to yourself and good to each other
visit
mindhelp.nba.com for wellness tips and
more information Anthony Davis just got
substituted out
there should have been a standing
ovation
it was barely even acknowledged I mean
you're right
the way he's played he has been
absolutely dominant